12 years ago
dub narration debration also the
narrator says 12 years ago a nine-tailed
fox suddenly appeared but the subtitles
say a long time ago a powerful
demon fox appeared with nine tails and i
don't know who to trust
that whole demon part feels like it
might be important hold the attack
and then nobody does including him this
feels like an attempt to foreshadow the
fourth hokage reference rather than an
actual instruction
is that are we just skipping over the
sudden appearance of a massive frog with
tongue piercings and sure you could say
they are tongue warts but
is that better maybe this is explained
in the future but why did the beast need
to be sealed in a human body
why not something else like stone or if
it needs to be a living thing how about
a turtle
those things live for a long time and
they're pretty easy to keep track of
we've certainly had our share of candle
sins in the sins universe but i've never
in my sin in life seen someone over
candle their baby
even demon fox babies don't deserve this
degree of over-candling endangerment
losers wannabes you'll never catch me
when your anime hero starts with the
same catch phrase as the gingerbread man
but then infuses it with about 68
more [ __ ] you may want to tone down
the cocky smart alec routine a tad
[Music]
i don't even have time for all the ways
this escape doesn't make sense i get it
show
naruto is magic and can bend space and
time and have picture perfect sheet
camouflage that shouldn't work in a 3d
environment
dang it i said i wasn't going to get
into it can we try that again
all the nope
that was too easy the only thing i hate
more than this naruto kid right now is
the dub dialogue nonsense
here's the rub choosing dubs over subs
is a flub the dub club who snubbed subs
rubs tubs of grubs on their nubs
subs drub dubs bub it was a good first
step to take paddlings out of schools
but i'm gonna go ahead and recommend we
also do away with tying children up on
the floor in front of their classmates
and fail-shaming them
fair because you missed it naruto
everyone will review the transformation
jutsu
suffering for the sins of others i mean
i basically get paid to do that and it's
still a sin
transformed into me god there was
something about the way he said good
there that gives me the no-no feelings
in my no-no place
we always pay for your screw-ups like i
care
we are quickly approaching making your
protagonist so unlikable i want to stop
watching territory naruto is basically
the tweenage version of caillou at this
point
just so we're all clear as to what just
happened naruto used his transformation
test to transform into a floating naked
sexy jutsu with convenient cloud cover
which made blood rocket forth from his
teacher's nostrils so hard it sent him
flying and then came back with an
enlarged rage head with nosebleed
tissues inserted into both nostrils
despite only being gone for a couple
seconds
guys i'm beginning to think anime may be
a bit exaggerated
i can't believe i'm saying this about a
lonely swing shot with birds chirping in
the background but this goes on for some
time
seriously 12 full seconds of this like
we haven't even had to slow this down
for me to do this in
it stays on the screen that long i mean
you know who the hokage are don't you
he most certainly does and you most
certainly do but the audience doesn't so
bring on more forced exposition slurping
your noodles
my god this kid's throat must be made
from heat resistant metal that bowl was
filled with ramen and steaming broth a
few seconds ago
then everyone will have to stop
disrespecting me and look up to me
believe it geez kid is every word you
say so important you have to shout talk
it
naruto's default verbal setting is hard
sell you want another bowl
i mean honestly if i'm gonna get through
this another bowl might be helpful
you can only wear the leaf headband when
you finally graduate from the academy
and become a ninja
i'll just point out that this symbol is
supposed to be a leaf and it is clearly
the profile of a swirly bird face
you've got to pass the test tomorrow is
it possible for a show to be 100
exposition
because i feel like that might have been
the goal here considering this is the
third time we've seen this swing i'm
beginning to wonder if it's a main
character do we find out later that
naruto has to ride the swing of destiny
to achieve his final form
i knew it also swing straddling i mean
he's the boy who
shh we're not allowed to talk about that
yes and i can tell by your polite
demeanor and otherwise upstanding
attitude that this is for sure a secret
that you and all your classmates would
have kept hidden this entire time
look at the pipes hanging off the bottom
of this no rails death balcony
i mean look at how many pipes are
bundled up there this is some serious
drainage and i can't imagine why they're
this important
if aruka complains about an inability to
sleep at night can we please all agree
his bed placement choices are lacking
who puts a bed directly under a window
with no curtains to cover the moon
especially when the moon is apparently
bright enough to illuminate everything
in the room
you mean the scroll of ceiling no yes
the scroll of ceiling let me tell you
about it as we yell to each other things
we already know
naruto has an armband accessory that i'm
unable to ignore any longer
i mean what a weird place to keep
lipstick it's a good thing it got
stabbed in his pre-existing leg bandage
mizuki used you to get the scroll for
himself for his own power
pro tip when watching anime anytime
someone is surprised pretend they're
constipated
it works and it's hilarious and is
somehow also a sin also we're not shown
where the scroll was originally held or
how naruto managed to get it i mean it's
pretty obvious it wasn't being hidden or
guarded all that well so the fact that
it hasn't been stolen at all to this
point is pretty impressive
[Laughter]
this swing may be the most important
animated inanimate object of all time
it made the revelation montage for
hagaki's sake
it may not show but he's always thinking
about the family he doesn't have
flashback narration backstory exposition
flashbacks duration position
naruto clearly attended the rickon stark
school of crawling away from things
i'll say it again for the back row if
you have the ninja speed and skills to
place yourself between someone in a
giant death star you probably have the
ninja speed and skills to just pull them
out of the way and save you both
although it was nice of him to line up
his back with the bullseye for max
visual appeal
when i lost my parents no one seemed to
care
oh yes this is the perfect time to wax
poetic about your backstory
you know while a murderous lunatic rages
in the tree branches with another
massive throwing star
in addition to the one already in your
back no no no rush
fight can wait you feel lonely and it
hurts inside
and i could have been there for you more
me man
a full minute has passed and now he's
bleeding tears and snot
this is a nightmare of emotion and i was
promised ninja
don't make me laugh not only is there no
way he could have heard aruka's
backstory from the branches but why is
he not attacking
kill the sensei let's go wait am i
rooting right
no ruto rolandomercials
this is not good right running on all
fours like that is really bad form i've
seen people do the naruto run and this
is not it
the seal that locks the fox spirit
inside of him
could be broken and the beast could come
out
now i describe my need for a bathroom
break somehow ends up in the show
how did you know that it was me
and not iruka because i'm
okay fine cool double fake out and such
but it sure is convenient that the
actual naruto also just happened to be
within earshot to hear this important
conversation
but his suffering only makes him
stronger that's it i'm officially
renaming this show swing kid you know
what they say about indicating your
protagonist's loneliness
it don't mean a thing if you don't show
that swing doo op dwop doo op doo op doo
op doo op dwow
the road gets tougher now that you're a
ninja or maybe the road gets harder
because he has a demon fox living inside
his body
yeah maybe that
you pooping if you've ever wanted to
know what it's like to probe into the
back end of cinema sins and learn our
deepest darkest secrets behind the sins
podcast is just what you need each week
writers aaron that's me today
that's me and jonathan yep discuss what
it takes to create the content that you
enjoy on youtube
hopefully enjoy they probably do i mean
even if they don't we talk about it
that's true i guess i'll just wrap this
up real quick
and let you know that you can listen to
behind the scenes here on youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep sticks and technology
sitting in a tree
i-n-t-e-r-f-a-c-i-n-g
she touched my peppy steve one shinobi
faced the nine-tailed fox in mortal
combat
this is really good i am
i am but you know what the worst part of
all is i
never learned to read
nobody likes me everybody hates me i
think i'll go eat words